بعد ان شادي ملف في ترسيم الحدود البحريه
الجنوبيه بين لبنان واسرائيل بدات الاحزاب
السياسيه من خلال اللجان النيابيه بمناقشه
قانون الملائم لانشاء صندوق سياده لاداره
العائدات من الثروه النفطيه في اختلاف
جدري بين الاقتراحات الاربعه المقدمين
اقتراح كتله التنميه والتحرير بتعطي وصايه
الى وزاره الماليه وهذا حيعوق عمل المجلس
براينا اقتراح كتله او التيار الوطني الحر
اعطى اكتر وصايا وزاره الطاقه ورؤسسه
الجمهوريه هلا الاقتراح الكتله جمهوريه
القويه او القوات اللبنانيه
واللقاء الديمقراطي فيها اكثر هامش
للاستقلالي الماليه والاداريه لا يجوز ان
ننشئ اليوم صندوق تتحكم فيه الاعتبارات
السياسيه كما تتحكم بالمؤسسات العامه
الاخرى
بحسب المتابعين تنص الاقتراحات على
استثمار الاموال من خلالي مشاريع انتاجيه
في لبنان تسهم في توفير فرص عمل للشباب
وتفتح الباب لتحفيز الاستثمار الخارجي
وتحسين البنا التحتيه
مليار دولار على الاقل تقديرات للسروال
الغازيه في لبنان اليوم بعد ما بضاعه في
السعر اربع خمس مرات صرنا بشكل طبيعي يعني
بنحكي ب 700 و800 مليار او نقرب اليوم
ممكن نستفيد منه بخطه اللي ممكن يوصلنا مع
الصندوق النقد الدولي
سياسيه وطائفيه بدات تظهر حول مرجعيه
اداره الصندوق السيادي للنفط والغاز في ظل
مراقبه شعبيه منعا للوقوع في فخ الهدر
والمحاصصه